bonjour monsieur tilton man merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur arte france
alors air france klm on l'a dit a réduit
ses vols de 90 80 avec 15% ses deux
filiales up et transavia ont cessé
toutes leurs activités l'action d'air
france a perdu plus de la moitié de sa
valeur en moins d'un mois
une chute brutale un forcément est-ce
que l'existence de la compagnie tout
simplement est menacé alors on n'est pas
sur une compagnie qui est parmi les plus
fragiles
déjà parce qu'à la base et ça faisait
quand même démarche qui était pas
totalement nuls il y avait des
compagnies qui sont déjà dans le rouge
depuis des années des années on pense
par exemple à l'italien mais y en a
d'autres on pense à des compagnies aussi
con pas d'attachés purement nationales
easyjet ryanair même norvégienne
aujourd'hui quel pays va se battre pour
sauver ryanair s'est pas laissée pas
l'irlande qui va continuer à vouloir
assurer des vols entre l'allemagne et la
grèce par contre air france
elle avait quand même une partie sa
flotte qui est en propriété alors que ce
qui est compliqué justement c'est quand
ils sont en location est également on
avait quand même un soutien national
serre que la france aujourd'hui va être
capable de sauver sa compagnie nationale
parce qu'il faut comprendre qu'une
compagnie aérienne est absolument
indispensable pour la relance de
l'économie
quand l'économie repartira dans quelques
mois vous l'avez dit vous avez cité bon
nombre de compagnies aériennes c'est
vraiment tout le secteur 1 planétaire et
qui est touchée on a évoqué des pertes
financières pouvant aller jusqu'à 113
milliards d'euros pour 2020 c'est énorme
c'est 0,13 pour cent du pib mondial
est-ce que selon vous ça pourrait être
encore plus grave
ce sera plus grave de toute façon là
vous donner un chiffre qui a été avancé
par l'iata
il ya maintenant plus d'une semaine et
qui était déjà multiplié par quatre par
rapport à la semaine précédente
on était à peu près à 30 milliards on
est passé à 115 milliards et ça c'était
avant l'interdiction des vols de
l'europe vers les états unis
et c'était avant de savoir qu'on aura 90
% de la flotte européenne qui serait
cloué au sol donc clairement cette
première estimation c'était à peu près
20% du chiffre d'affaires annuel qui
s'envolait là on est bien au delà et on
va se diriger vers des dizaines de
faillite
je vous passe faut pas oublier qu'il ya
sur un secteur qui est structurellement
relativement fragile avec des marges qui
sont en dessous de 5% depuis des années
l'année dernière sans aucune crise vous
avez eu 25 compagnies qu'en fait
faillite
donc là la question les compagnies
faibles vont tout disparaître
c'est une certitude celle qui n'ont pas
le soutien d'un état quel que soit leur
taille aujourd'hui elles sont en danger
on parle parfois de renationalisation
vous avez parlé d'entreprises comme
alitalia voilà est-ce que c'est une
solution possible
c'est une solution temporaire il faut
pas que la gestion de la compagnie
redevienne nationale parce qu'évidemment
il ya une certaine efficacité qui était
obtenue par la concurrence et par les
différents systèmes qui aujourd'hui est
très pertinent par contre le fait de
pouvoir
ponctuellement apporter des fonds bat
notamment en faisant des augmentations
de capital ce qui a priori va avoir lieu
pour air france permet à la compagnie
d'assurer les remboursements ses crédits
et d'éviter de faire faillite
parce qu'évidemment ben si vous n'avez
pas la possibilité d'assurer vos crédits
vous passez sur l'auteur de la fuite
et ça c'est pas simplement un chômage
partiel c'est vraiment une compagnie qui
pourraient disparaître
donc vous avez un certain nombre de pays
qui vont tenter de sauver leurs
compagnies nationales
on le sait l'italie alors que la
compagnie objectivement aurait dû
disparaître ba essaie quand même de
continuer à soutenir son industrie
nationale
peut-être que la roumanie va faire la
même chose peut être que beaucoup de
pays la corée du sud le singapour
également certainement si ça continue
comme ça aux états unis american
airlines est peut-être la compagnie qui
est la plus fragile
aeroflot également une compagnie qui n'a
pas dans une très très bonne santé
financière
toutes ces compagnies là auront besoin
pour survivre de leur soutien de leurs
pays notamment par des renationalisation
partielle mais ça peut être des choses
qui vont durer quelques mois jusqu'à ce
qu'on repasse sur des barques bases
saines et ensuite pour pouvoir laisser
le privé géré la compagnie normalement
voilà donc mon de l'aéronautique
également en crise merci beaucoup xavier
un tim badman d'avoir été avec nous cet
après midi je le rappelle vous êtes
spécialiste aéronautique chez cgi
consulting merci beaucoup